This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. And this is a video episode that we made with Vox. So, if you haven't already, turn on your screen and look at it. It'll make much more sense that way. You probably know how this symbol is supposed to make you feel. And this one. This one too, even if you're not exactly sure what it means.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。这是一期我们与Vox合作制作的视频节目。所以，如果你还没看的话，打开屏幕看看吧。那样看会更容易理解。你可能知道这些符号本该让你产生什么样的感觉。这个也是。还有这个，即使你不确定它确切的意思。
But what about this? This symbol, the Jolly Roger, was once one of the most feared symbols in the world. It represented death, pirates, and poison. But today, it's associated more with treasure, lockbuster movies, or Halloween, than actual danger. We are surrounded by icons that warn us what to stay away from, what not to do, what to be afraid of. But how do you design a symbol in a way that will last across generations and languages?
那这个呢？这个符号，骷髅旗，曾经是世界上最令人恐惧的符号之一。它代表着死亡、海盗和毒药。但今天，它与宝藏、大片或万圣节的联系，比与实际危险的联系更多。我们周围到处都是警告我们远离、不要做什么、要害怕什么的图标。但是，你该如何设计一个能跨越世代和语言的符号呢？
It turns out that is an incredibly hard thing to do. Back in the early 20th century, there was an urgent need for a new kind of warning symbol. At the time, there was no universal standard for communicating the presence of dangerous biological materials. Laboratories at the US Army used an inverted blue triangle, those at the Navy used a pink rectangle. The Universal Postal Convention used a white staff and snake on a violet background. There was no consistency in the visual language used to communicate risk.
事实证明，这极其困难。20世纪初，人们迫切需要一种新型的警告符号。当时，对于如何传达危险生物材料的存在，并没有统一的标准。美国陆军的实验室使用倒置的蓝色三角形，海军的实验室使用粉色矩形。万国邮政联盟在紫色背景上使用白色的蛇杖。在传达风险的视觉语言上，没有任何一致性。
That was dangerous and could lead to accidental infections. So in 1966, a group of engineers and designers at Dow Chemical set out to create the best possible icon for biohazardous materials. They laid out six design criteria. First it needed to be visually striking so that it would draw immediate attention. That ruled out simple shapes like those from the Navy and Army. It also had to be unique and unambiguous in order not to be confused with symbols used for other purposes. That ruled out the snake and staff which has multiple versions and has a pretty vague meaning as a general symbol
这很危险，可能导致意外感染。因此，1966年，陶氏化学的一组工程师和设计师着手为生物危害材料创造最佳图标。他们提出了六项设计标准。首先，它需要视觉上引人注目，以便立即引起注意。这排除了海军和陆军使用的简单形状。它还必须独特且明确，以免与用于其他目的的符号混淆。这排除了蛇杖，因为它有多个版本，作为通用符号含义相当模糊。
for medicine. On top of that it had to be quickly recognizable and easily recalled. It had to be easy to stencil and rotationally symmetrical in order to appear identical from all angles. And lastly, it had to be acceptable to groups of all backgrounds. So the Dow Chemical team designed an experiment. Charles Baldwin, an environmental health engineer behind the experiment, said that the team wanted something that was memorable but meaningless, so we could educate people as to what it means.
对于医学来说。最重要的是，它必须能被快速识别并易于记忆。它必须易于模版印刷，并且具有旋转对称性，以便从各个角度看起来都一样。最后，它必须被各种背景的群体所接受。因此，陶氏化学团队设计了一个实验。该实验背后的环境健康工程师查尔斯·鲍德温表示，团队想要一些令人难忘但没有意义的东西，这样我们就可以教育人们它意味着什么。
They showed a set of 24 symbols to 300 people from 25 American cities. There were six newly designed biohazard markers and 18 common symbols, things like Mr. Pina, the Texaco Star, the Shell Oil symbol, the Red Cross, and a Swastika. Participants were asked to guess the meaning of each one, which was used to assign each one a meaningfulness score.
他们向来自美国25个城市的300人展示了一组24个符号。其中包括六个新设计的生物危害标记和18个常见符号，比如皮纳先生、德士古之星、壳牌石油符号、红十字会和纳粹万字旗。参与者被要求猜测每个符号的含义，这被用来为每个符号分配一个意义得分。
A week later, the same participants were shown those original 24 symbols plus 36 more. They were asked to identify which symbols they remembered seeing in the previous round of the study. Among the six competing biohazard designs, this one stood out. It scored the highest in memorability, but the lowest in meaningfulness, so it was unforgettable, but also a totally blank slate for designers who wanted to give it meaning. And with that, it became a national standard. It's easy to overlook how much visual communication work these symbols are doing.
一周后，同样的参与者被展示了最初的24个符号加上另外36个符号。他们被要求识别出他们在研究的前一轮中记得见过的符号。在六个竞争的生物危害设计中，这一个脱颖而出。它在可记忆性方面得分最高，但在意义方面得分最低，所以它令人难忘，但对于想要赋予它意义的设计师来说，它也是一张完全的白纸。就这样，它成为了国家标准。人们很容易忽视这些符号在视觉传达方面所做的工作。
They're simple, you'll need a straight edge and a compass to recreate them. And unlike most other hazard symbols, they don't reference an existing physical object or idea. But they've remained iconic for decades, helping people recognize serious dangers that may remain a threat for thousands of years to come. And that raises the question, could the meaning of those symbols stand the test of time? Few people have pondered that question quite like Gregory Benford. the question, could the meaning of those symbols stand the test of time? Few people have pondered that question quite like Gregory Benford. He's a physicist and science fiction author, and in the 1990s he was invited to work on
它们很简单，你需要直尺和圆规才能重现它们。与其他大多数危险符号不同，它们不参考现有的物理对象或想法。但几十年来，它们一直保持着标志性地位，帮助人们识别可能在未来数千年内持续构成威胁的严重危险。这就提出了一个问题：这些符号的含义能经受住时间的考验吗？很少有人像格雷戈里·本福德那样深入思考过这个问题。他是一位物理学家和科幻小说作家，在20世纪90年代，他受邀参与了
the Waste Isolation Pilot Project, or WIP. The WIP is a massive storage site for radioactive waste in the southeastern plains of New Mexico, organized by the U.S. Department of Energy. Benford was brought on to help calculate the probability that someone or something would intrude on the site for as long as church or the core of the Jewish religion, which tells us something about what really lasts. The meaning of a symbol can change over time, like the Jolly Roger, which wouldn't work for the radioactive threat at the whip.
废物隔离试验工厂（WIPP）。WIPP是美国能源部在新墨西哥州东南部平原组织的一个巨大的放射性废物储存点。本福德被请来帮助计算某人或某物闯入该地点的概率，时间跨度长达教会或犹太教核心存在的时间，这告诉我们什么才是真正持久的。符号的含义会随着时间而改变，就像骷髅旗一样，它对WIPP的放射性威胁不起作用。
If you're approaching the whip facility and you see a skull and crossbones, you might think, hey, this is where the pirates buried their treasure. So how do you indicate a long lasting danger across any language? Since the 1970s, engineers andthropologists, physicists, and behavioral scientists have proposed different solutions to that problem. One strategy was to add context to the symbol. By illustrating cause and effect in a three-part cartoon like this, designers could communicate the idea even if the symbol lost its meaning.
如果你接近WIPP设施，看到骷髅和交叉骨，你可能会想，嘿，这就是海盗埋藏宝藏的地方。那么，如何跨越任何语言来指示一种持久的危险呢？自20世纪70年代以来，工程师、人类学家、物理学家和行为科学家提出了解决该问题的不同方案。一种策略是为符号添加背景。通过像这样用三部分漫画说明因果关系，即使符号失去了意义，设计师也能传达出这个想法。
But this kind of visual communication still made a lot of assumptions about the user, that they would read left to right, that they would understand causality between frames, and of course that the drawing itself would last millennia of wear and tear. So other designers started to focus on creating a warning without inscribed communication, by altering the shape of the location itself. And that yield the designs like this. Spikefields for bidding blocks, giant pyramids, these designs capitalized on natural instincts of fear and discomfort to keep people away. But even then, they weren't foolproof. Designers couldn't be sure whether they would be
但这种视觉传达方式仍然对用户做了很多假设，即他们会从左到右阅读，他们会理解框架之间的因果关系，当然，图画本身也会经受住千年的磨损。因此，其他设计师开始专注于在没有文字交流的情况下创造警告，通过改变地点本身的形状。这产生了像这样的设计。禁止进入的尖刺场、巨大的金字塔，这些设计利用了恐惧和不适的本能来让人远离。但即便如此，它们也不是万无一失的。设计师无法确定它们会被
perceived as terrifying or fascinating. Conflict between these two urges. You want people to notice it, but you don't want people to go there. Those are always going to fight each other. So without symbols, without basic illustrations, without physical structures, how can you effectively communicate a warning? That's where the more philosophical design solutions come in. In 1984, the German Journal of Semiotics published a series of solutions from various scholars. linguist Thomas Cibiak proposed creating an atomic priesthood where an exclusive political group would use its own rituals and mist to preserve information about the radioactive areas. And philosophers Francois Bastide and Paulo Fobre proposed to genetically engineer bioluminescent cats that would glow in the presence of radioactivity.
视为恐怖还是迷人。这两种冲动之间存在冲突。你希望人们注意到它，但你又不希望人们去那里。这两者总是会相互抵触。那么，没有符号、没有基本插图、没有物理结构，你如何有效地传达警告呢？这就是更具哲学意义的设计方案发挥作用的地方。1984年，德国符号学杂志发表了一系列来自不同学者的解决方案。语言学家托马斯·西比亚克提议建立一个原子祭司阶层，由一个排他的政治团体利用其自身的仪式和神话来保存有关放射性区域的信息。哲学家弗朗索瓦·巴斯蒂德和保罗·福布雷提议通过基因工程培育出在放射性存在时会发光的猫。
By creating songs and traditions about the danger of glowing cats, the warning could last as long as the oldest relics of civilization we have. Culture. There's no definitive solution for warning people far into the future, but designing clear, inclusive symbols will continue to be a fundamental part of how we keep people safe. We will change, and so will the ways we communicate visually. Our warning symbols will just have to change along with us. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
通过创作关于发光猫危险的歌曲和传统，警告可以像我们拥有的最古老的文明遗迹一样持久。文化。对于警告遥远未来的人们，没有最终的解决方案，但设计清晰、包容的符号将继续成为我们保障人们安全的基本组成部分。我们将改变，我们进行视觉交流的方式也将改变。我们的警告符号将不得不与我们一起改变。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。